faut pas être a vendu moi je sais que
j'ai une ceinture trop serré pour nous
tous c'est à dire que quand aucun cas ni
pour de l'argent ni pour le succès pour
la notoriété tout ça j'irai faire un rap
qui est pas propre à moi aujourd'hui il
ya des mecs ou des filles vont faire du
rap un peu près par procuration quoi ils
sont formateurs non c'est pour ça que tu
as été volés à son collègue du clonage
non moi je suis moi et tu peux pas être
moi c'est qu'aujourd'hui pour moi le rap
c'est toujours un message
et faut qu'il soit perçu de la façon
dont tu veux qu'ils soient perçus
il faut dire des choses ça sert à rien
de faire du rap ourdir un pour rien
raconter parce que le petit 8 ans où le
petit 12 ans il va tu écoutais mais tu
vas rien lui apporter et on sait
qu'aujourd'hui le rap ça peut apporter
quelque chose